benvenuti sia questo nuovissimo video
sono poi anche io ci siamo surround four
che hanno sbagliato che quello che
prendiamo tutti con l'ascensore quando
non solo fare filoso come non sono meno
lei sono già hubris sono ubriaco io sto
facendo niente si sta si muove da solo
questo è già un problema prova per ron
prosor credo che abbiano voluto
guarda quanto ubriaco sto tizio e sto
tornando a casa avevo sbagliato better
used in the year meglio usare il meteo
dice che non funzionerà nelle vecchie
sembra un'esagerazione stavo prendendo
le elevator comunque a prescindere cioè
io non ho mai visto cioè io non so cosa
si provi esser ubriachi perché non
sono state però non riesco a comprendere
il perché debbano mettere un personaggio
che ruota da solo
la cosa non è molto senso prova boe
giorno sono a metà piano fosse uscire
ogni trancia metà noto visto non
esistono ecco infatti noi non sono
uscito porca [ __ ]
giorno questo è il piano sbaglia il
piano sbaglia
giorno e poi ha fatto benissimo se non
fosse ubriaco si ma devo darli qua
ragazzi non si vede niente e ho capito
che devi turn on how che qua c'è
qualcosa
serve mi scusi devo solo prendere il le
cadute un polmone devo prendere il
generatore dell'elevator che non so dove
sia
c'è un bacarozzo sulla costola se n'è
accorto di qua perfetto male che c'è
roba illuminata perché sono puntati che
vado in giro si vede niente
sì io sto cercando per fare mettere a
posto l'ascensore posso passare qua
con esso che
i ragazzi sentono i rumori orribili cosa
devo fare
la pensa così pensavo girasse pure
questa non è una torcia minchia meno
male sono cagato nelle mutande per va
bene devo madonna che brutta sensazione
comunque sono giù briaco non fa quello
che più che di
almè almeno vedo quel buio per ragazzi
non c'è madonna pensavo fosse un
attaccato al soffitto mi avrebbe fatto
una carica che non avete idea
eccola generato nelle bettole e lì
dietro devo spaccarlo con un pieni porco
ma che cazzo diciamo che questa orribile
terribile mostro battibile cosa ho visto
andiamoci all'esca via di qua da mio
piedi porto madonna ragazzi ore o bis
non l'aveva incredibile suo gioco
incredibile successo gioco veramente che
datemi un piede di porco beh vi prego ma
non per spaccare per il taglio in testa
col sa dov'è
cosa devo fare qui santo iddio
che madonna è stato che cazzo era ma
come se la sono studiata bene sta roba
madonna mi sono cagato addosso
raga un gioco pazzesco attenzione molto
pericoloso maniaco alto due metri e
mezzo va bene 30 anni tagli su tutto il
corpo io avrei bisogno di un piede di
porco se ha voglia di darmelo
aperto tu la porta bene grazie
che bello che ho sbagliato piano proprio
mentre c'è un maniaco della madonna di
dio
9 non ci posso andare in a ma non posso
andare di là
ma vacci tu si apre non si apre una sega
bene
a [ __ ] quanto grosso
noi abbiamo ragazzi ma incredibili sesso
gioco e madonna non provo ste robe dai
tempi di out plus ma di che parliamo c'è
l'hai un piede di porco ti prego il
codice è dietro il cabinato rosso
quale cabinato lo zio della madonna dai
non so neanche dove sia sto coso rosso
madonna
che succede è cambiata la musica
fosse entrato posso entrare qui che non
so se non c'è più nessuno che
se n'è andato lo zio se n'è andato lo
zio
non so dove sia il cabinato rosso ma
devo andare al cabinato rosso ragazzi
e mi scusi
avrei bisogno di un cap in area possa
andare di qua che mi pare fosse lì qua
ma non vorrei una cagata
il codice dietro il cabinato rosso ma
qual è questo qua a questo il rosso
c'è la foto
bello
è un gioco di merda è un gioco che merda
io non lo scrivo perché giocano siamo
nel 2021 io devo ancora fare gli horror
come nel 2002 basta qual è il cabinato
rosso questo c'era un altro ma non trovo
niente
questo non è e sarà questo è l'ultimo
poi non è proprio
maron arrogarmi questo qua
eccolo eccolo
1990 nice
mi scusi di interesse per donare di
prender 8 infarti prenderò il quale ho
già preso e non potete di farlo nello
stesso punto almeno cambiamo
che sento passi cos'è cos'è
990 1990 1990 1990 sento passi sento
passi orribile
disney pixar presenta
niente
e volevo
aiuto e tu madre morta ok c'è un tizio
dentro
a posto
[Musica]
19 09 09 dove non avevo inter 0 1
aspetta che c'è qualcosa qui c'è
qualcosa basta ma cos'è
a sfondare la porta sta arrivando sta
arrivando
sta arrivando sono morti sono morti sono
morto sono morto morto sua morte sono
morto non è arrivato perché non so
quello che facendo il codice siete voi
non lo sto facendo perché mi sto
cambiando addosso quando in italia non
posso fare tutto quello che voglio
capito quindi adesso lo faccio mi giro e
lo faccio 1990 1990 1990 1990
arrivederci
ecco poi tutto sto casino per trovare un
tool per trovare un picco al costo porta
eccolo ne prenderei anche io prenderei
anche la sega nel dubbio proprio a
dargliela in the fire in the face è un
po grosso lo zio però secondo me
potrebbe aiutare a difendersi
si è sfondata la porta alcun nardò posso
andare a vedere cosa c'è dentro
scusi ma che cazzo stai ha fatto ha
dentro una sedia della
madonna che horror pazzesco raga ma che
cacchio è
vedo nulla se smacchiate la cosa ciò
non sto vedendo niente so sto
vacillando questo succede
cos'è lang over the kill hai bevuto zio
ok elevator
ko
ok caprino per una donna
ok è cosa da fare
e lo attivato cosa ho fatto arrivederci
manutenzione fatta teoricamente dovrebbe
bastare
ha funzionato
giorno bongio io vado nila vado di
lasciare una l'ho vista che c'è una
porta e bellissimo questo posto ben sia
pure lì è che io vado vado a vedere
delle cose chi
sta scendendo l'ascensore mi scusi che
può e lento e adesso arriva io vado vado
dell'ascensore mi scusi non accetta lei
rilasci l'accetta arrivederci
arrivederci a rio decibel comunque
bisogna sempre essere sempre essere
gentili e cordiali con la gente mi
raccomando eh abbiamo finito questa pur
questo gioco di che cassetto sono ancora
il processo è andato se volete bene
bellissimo però che il video vi sia
piaciuto io ho adorato questo gioco
adesso lo vado a rigiocare lo vado di
giocare di nuovo perché mi è piaciuto
piedi iscrivetevi al canale ragazzi e
spero che gli sia piaciuto il video
all'interno
[Musica]